- Jazz and I are looking at the email
of the things we can't eat.
Can't eat eggs.
- Oh, fuck.
(bright music)
- I really like any type of food
except for like really,
really vegetable-heavy foods.
- I'm not used to looking at labels.
I wanna get a lot of knowledge
into what goes into foods
and I think hopefully my
diet's better after this,
and hopefully I learn
how to cook something.
- I just went on this journey of having
healthy relationships with
myself, food and exercise,
and I'm just excited to
start something new and do it
in a healthy, positive mental space.
- We're going on our
first grocery mission.
I don't know what to look for.
Maybe we'll just go to
what we normally get
and then look for options.
We've made it to the fruit section
which we can guarantee is vegan.
- I found some meatless meats.
I'm here for sausage!
Not in my sexual life, just in this life.
- [Lindsay] We're going
for the safe options.
- Safe option.
Probably not that healthy
but spaghetti's good.
- I feel like I'm trying
things that I've always
wanted to try but now trying
stuff I have a reason to.
- I'm actually excited.
I got a lot (chuckles).
I don't know if I can
even eat all of these.
I probably will because
I'm gonna be hungry.
- Alright, let's try this vegan sausage.
I put some mustard on
it - that's vegan too.
Consistency, a little
questionable, but taste?
Very good!
Oh my god, that actually
kinda tastes like sausage.
- [Jazzmyne] We have
a little meeting today
and here's all the food that I can't eat.
- Alright so we had catered lunch today
and there was tons of sandwiches
all of which had meat except one,
and it has tofu.
I do not like tofu but I
am sticking it out today.
- Oh!
- Me and my friend were
talking and she's vegan.
She was saying how she gets
annoyed when people do this shit
because he will starve and
just don't end up eating
because they can't eat anything.
And so I've really been
making it a priority
to make sure I'm not starving and I'm not.
I feel very full and I'm eating vegetables
and I'm eating fruits and I feel good.
(she laughs)
- So today I realized that
not all vegan food is healthy.
I know that's kind of dumb to realize.
I snacked a lot.
I had Oreos.
I had chips.
There was a lot of things
you can eat when you're vegan
and not all of them are great for you
so I think from now on I
kinda need to watch myself,
make sure I'm just
getting nutrients I need.
- So it's about 2:30 AM.
Usually right now, I would make
an egg sandwich with cheese
but I can't because I can't have eggs.
So my lunch today is sausageless
sausage and broccoli.
- I'm at the mall and I keep smelling
Wetzel's freaking Pretzels
and I can't eat it
and it's killing me.
- We are on our way to go
to an all-vegan restaurant!
- [Girls] Whoo!
- We're here.
We're looking at the menus.
The best part of this is that we can
just choose whatever's on this menu.
- All vegan.
- So after being vegan for a week,
I've realized that it's
truly fucking amazing.
The meatless meat options,
it still made me feel
like I was eating meat but
I felt better about it,
honestly because I knew
I wasn't eating animals.
- I think it really just
opened my eyes to the fact that
I just need to start reading
my labels of the things I eat
because honestly, the things
that even are good to eat,
that don't have vegan
stuff in it, I'm like,
oh my God, they have this
amount of sugar and other things
that I should be looking
at and paying attention to.
- I'm really glad I did this challenge
and from now on I can
definitely see myself
exploring a lot more options on food.
- So yes, I will be
continuing some vegan habits
but also yes, I am
driving to Korean barbecue
at this very moment.
(crowd chatter)
- I just ate an egg.
I just ate a fucking egg!
(soft music)